the Joe Rogan experience it I don't know
what to do with that you're an MMA fan
yeah what do you think about the UFC's
decision to have fights next weekend on
an island I don't know we don't know
where it is I'm trying to figure out
what I'm doing if I'm going to it or not
I don't know we're dating yeah I don't
know where it is I don't even know if
it's in America literally right now as
of right now I don't know [ __ ] I have no
information okay so first off it's in an
island like I saw like is it's fight
island it's literally a storyline event
sure that means yes
Enter the Dragon this is like I don't
know who the Bruce Lee is or the Chuck
Norris
should I get a Chinese kung fu outfit
and do commentary with a kung fu alpha
nah 100 that be culturally appropriate
at this no you know what I'll do I went
on there Bruce Lee tracksuits
that wouldn't be culturally
appropriating well they'd just be fandom
and in time of coronavirus you get a
cultural appropriation pass okay I heard
yeah I I to me I think that's great
because if it's messaged correctly to
show that we are while maintaining sort
of social distancing all those kinds of
things we're trying to fight to bring
our society back okay let me pause right
there there's no social distancing in a
[ __ ] cage fight yeah okay they're on
top of each other sweating each other's
mouths there's not gonna be there's
gonna be if Tony Ferguson's fighting
there's gonna be blood for sure
everybody fights Tony first it looks
like they fell off a train so there's
gonna be blood the cyclical distancing
you want to avoid is large crowds right
one on one one on one so do what if
everybody gets tested yeah you think
that's accessible how accessible are
tests right now so in America it's point
seven percent of the population have
been tested that in terms of testing
everybody that's not accessible but in
terms of testing special like
investments of special events yeah so
that's possible what do you think they
would do if like there's a lot of good
fights in this car by the way
Jazze no roses strike his fight and
friend is a frightening condom yeah I
mean come on
gah no and Rosen strike that is that is
a [ __ ] crazy fight what if one of
those guys test positive what if you
know what if just engage he taste test
positive the guys supposed to be
fighting first and do you go ahead or
not they could obviously have to ask the
opponent if they want to yeah I I'm a
little bit Russian I I would I would go
ahead I'll go ahead and I don't know so
my main concern is how was the general
public interpret it because you want to
do everything you do now should be done
in a way that is one is positive like
inspires us for it towards the community
and to gets us to do the right thing
scientifically I don't know if AK ovid
infected person fighting would inspire
others to say oh it's okay if they're
doing it's okay from well I don't think
they would allow it I have a feeling
that if someone did test positive they
would kick him off the card yeah
probably should say kick them off the
card or should say
remove them from the card I take it back
that's probably the right thing to do I
would imagine it has to be the right
thing to do and then you would also have
to quarantine the people that worked
with him in training camp and you enough
to test everybody
yeah that's by the way what contact
tracing is yeah once you find somebody
honest and there's a technology for I
mean thatthat sort of the interesting
infrastructure there but I still I love
the idea that they're pushing forward
and doing the fights there's a lot of
people that are very upset with it it's
um it's very it's very controversial the
whole thing's contra why do you think
that effect because they don't want
anybody to do anything out of the norm
of social distancing and of quarantine
and you know what we're on lockdown
right now and for them look even Nevada
which relies almost entirely on casino
money I mean not Vegas at least Vegas
relies almost entirely on casino money
right all the other businesses are so
supported by the casinos those casinos
are
the [ __ ] down cannot have the fights in
Vegas
[Applause]